au nom de l'assemblée générale j'ai
l'honneur de souhaiter la bienvenue à
l'organisation des nations unies à son
excellence monsieur joseph byden
président des états unis d'amérique et
je l'invite à prendre la parole devant
l'assemblée bravo
monsieur le président monsieur le
secrétaire général mesdames et messieurs
à toutes celles qui se consacre à la
noble mission de cette institution
toutes celles et ceux là un honneur pour
moi de m'adresser à vous pour la
première fois en tant que président des
états unis nous nous réunissons
à un moment de souffrance et de
possibilités exceptionnelles nous avons
temps perdu à cause de cette pandémie
qui continue de provoquer des décès de
par le monde et qui a un tel impact sur
nos existences
nous sommes en deuil et plus de 4,5
millions de personnes ont perdu la vie
des personnes de toutes nations de
toutes origines chaque décès est une
tragédie individuelle mais notre deuil
partagé nous rappelle que notre avenir
commun sera tributaire de notre capacité
de reconnaître une humanité partagée la
nécessité d'agir de concert
mesdames et messieurs
nous avons un choix clair et urgent
à faire
alors que nous entamons un entamons
cette décennie décisive pour l'humanité
une décennie qui définira notre avenir
de communauté mondiale nous sommes face
indé et crises qui sont autant
d'occasions à saisir à condition de
pouvoir mobiliser
l'ensemble du monde et saisir ces
occasions est-ce que nous allons oeuvrer
de concert pour sauver des vies vaincre
lakovic 19 partout prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour nous préparer à la
prochaine pandémie car prochaine
pandémie il y aura où serons-nous
incapable d'utiliser les outils à notre
disposition alors que de nouveaux
variants plus virulents se propage
allons nous relever le défi
des changements climatiques qui provoque
des ravages partout dans le monde avec
ces phénomènes météorologiques extrêmes
ou
subir on nous met lé sécheresse les
incendies les ouragans les canicules la
hausse du niveau des mers
pourrons nous défendre protéger la
dignité de l'être humain les droits
humains
qui est à l'origine de la création de
cette institution il a 70 ans est-ce que
nous allons pouvoir renforcer les
piliers du système international y
compris la charte des nations unies la
déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme alors que nous cherchons à
façonner l'émergence des nouvelles
technologies en contrant de nouvelles
menaces ou alors allons-nous laisser ses
principes universels être foulés aux
pieds
dans cette quête de pouvoir politique
pure et simple pour moi la réponse que
nous donnons à ces questions aujourd'hui
la question de savoir s'ils ont choisi
de se battre pour notre avenir commun ou
non aura des conséquences sur les
générations à venir en d'autres mots
pour moi nous sommes elle à un point
d'inflexion un tournant de l'histoire et
je suis ici aujourd'hui présents pour
vous dire comment les etats-unis
comptent travailler aux côtés de nos
partenaires de nos alliés pour répondre
à ces questions mon nouveau gouvernement
s'est engagé à mener le monde vers un
avenir de paix et de prospérité pour
tous et toutes au lieu de continuer à
livrer les guerres d'hier nous avons le
regard rivé et nous consacrons nos
ressources sur les défis à relever pour
notre avenir commun vaincre la pandémie
faire face à la crise climatique
gérer l'évolution des dynamiques de
pouvoir mondial façonner les règles du
montre des questions de commerce
de cyber sécurité et de technologies
émergentes faire face à la menace
terroriste
actuelle
nous avons mis un terme à vingt années
de conflit en afghanistan
et alors que s'achève cette période de
guerre nous marquions l'avènement d'une
période de diplomatie nous utilisons le
pouvoir de notre aide au développement
pour investir dans de nouvelles façons
de venir en aide aux populations de par
le monde nous renouvelons défendons la
démocratie nous prouvons que quelle que
soit la difficulté la complexité des
problèmes que nous aurons à affronter un
gouvernement du peuple par le peuple
reste encore et toujours la meilleure
façon de venir en aide à tous nos
peuples alors que les etats-unis se
concentre sur les priorités et les
régions du monde telles que la région
indo pacifique est
parmi les plus importantes aujourd'hui
et demain nous le faisons en coopération
avec nos alliés et nos partenaires et
les institutions multilatérales telles
que les nations unies dans l'objectif de
renforcer
notre capacité de relever ces défis
mondiaux il y à une vérité fondamentale
de ce 21e siècle
en tant que communauté un mondial en
tant que pays individuels notre succès
dépend du succès d'autrui nous devons
répondre aux aspirations de notre peuple
et pour ce faire travailler avec le
reste du monde pour garantir leur avenir
il nous faut travailler de concert avec
nos partenaires pour parvenir à un
avenir partagé notre sécurité notre
prospérité
nos libertés même son plus reliée à mes
yeux que jamais par le passé et donc je
pense qu'il nous faut travailler
ensemble comme nous ne l'avons jamais
fait au cours des huit derniers mois
j'ai donné là priorité à la
revitalisation d'un partenariat de nos
alliances
reconnaissant leur rôle clé pour la
sécurité et la stabilité des états unis
nous avons
réitéré notre attachement à l'article 5
à l'otan nous travaillons avec nos
partenaires sont de nouveau concept
stratégique qui permettront à nos
alliances de mieux faire face aux défis
d'aujourd'hui et de demain nous avons
renouvelé notre engagement envers
l'union européenne un partenaire
absolument essentiel pour relever tout
un train de
défis auxquels notre monde de se heurte
aujourd'hui nous avons revu à la hausse
le partenariat avec l'australie l'inde
le japon les états unis dans le cadre du
dialogue de sécurité kadri latéral pour
relever les défis de la sécurité
sanitaire la sécurité climatique ou
encore les technologies émergentes nous
avons travaillé avec les organisations
régionales de la zone de l'union
africaine de l'organisation des états
américains afin de nous concentrer sur
les besoins les plus urgents des
populations des besoins d'une meilleure
santé de meilleures perspectives
économiques nous sommes de nouveau à la
table des négociations dans les
enceintes internationales et en
particulier au sein des nations unies
pour concentrer toute notre attention et
stimuler une action mondiale relever
ensemble les défis communs au sein de
l'organisation mondiale pour la santé
nous travaillons à nouveau en étroite
coopération nous soutenons le kovacs
pour fournir des vaccins dans le monde
ne pense sauver des vies nous avons
rejoint la cour de paris sur le climat
et
nous espérons briguer un siège au
conseil des droits de l'homme des
nations unies l'année prochaine alors
que les états unis cherchent à mobiliser
l'action nous allons non seulement
utilisé l'exemple de notre pouvoir mais
surtout le pouvoir de l'exemple
sachez ceci les états unis continueront
de se défendre de défendre ses alliés
contre des attaques y compris des
menaces terroristes alors que nous nous
préparons à recourir à la force si cela
s'avère nécessaire mais pour défendre
les intérêts vitaux des états unis y
compris face à des menaces imminentes
il faut que la mission soit clair et
réaliste mené avec le consentement
éclairé du peuple américain et dans la
mesure du possible en partenariat avec
nos alliés
la puissance militaire américaine
doit être utilisé en ultime recours ça
ne doit pas être la première solution ça
ne doit pas être utilisée pour
régler tous les problèmes qui
surviennent de par le monde aujourd'hui
les plus grandes préoccupations du monde
ne peuvent pas être réglés par le seul
recours à la force les bombes et les
balles ne nous défendrons pas contre
lacko vie de 19 voulait varions à venir
pour lutter contre la pandémie nous
avons besoin de la science de la volonté
politique collective nous devons agir
maintenant pour administrer le vaccin le
plus rapidement possible pour élargir
l'accès à l'oxygène aux tests aux
traitements pour sauver des vies dans le
monde entier et pour l'avenir il nous
faut créer un nouveau mécanisme de
financement de la sécurité sanitaire
mondiale en faisant fond sur
l'aide au développement existantes et
sur un conseil mondial de la santé doté
des outils dont nous avons besoin pour
identifier une pandémie et émergentes
qui nous permettra d'agir immédiatement
dans et déjà les états unis ont consacré
plus de 15 milliards de
l'art à la riposte mondiale contre la
copie des 19 nous avons expédié plus de
160 millions de doses de vaccins de
covin 19 vers d'autres pays notamment
130 millions de doses de nos propres
réserves et
un demi million de
vaccins pfizer qui seront donnés via
kovacs des avions transportant des
vaccins venant des états unis ont déjà
atterri dans une centaine de pays les
peuples du monde entier ont reçu une
petite dose d'espoir comme m'a dit un
jour une fermière à une infirmière
américaine une petite dose d'espoir
sans condition aucune et demain
les états unis vont accueillir un sommet
sur la colline 19 et je vais annoncer
d'autres engagements alors que nous
continuons de lutter contre la coved 19
et nous allons rendre des comptes et de
la réalisation de nos objectifs
fixés avec trois grands objectifs sauver
des vies maintenant vaccinée le monde et
reconstruire en mieux
cette année a été une année de mort de
ravages provoqués par la crise
climatique les phénomènes
météorologiques extrêmes que nous avons
vu survenir aux quatre coins du monde
que vous avez vu ressentie également
représente comme le secrétaire général
l'a dit une alerte rouge pour
l'humanité les scientifiques et les
experts nous le disent nous arrivons
bientôt à un point de non retour
pour
atteindre l'objectif de limiter le
réchauffement de la planète à 1,5 degré
celsius toutes les nations doivent
revoir à la hausse leurs ambitions
lorsque nous nous retrouverons à glasgow
pour la coop 26
et à la suite de cela il faudra encore
revoir à la hausse nos ambitions au fil
du temps au moins d'avril j'ai un an
c'est le nouvel objectif ambitieux des
états unis en vertu de l'accord de paris
de réduire les émissions des gaz à effet
de serre des etats-unis de 50 à 50 2 %
en deçà un des niveaux de 2005 et ce
d'ici 2030 alors que nous cherchons à
parvenir à une économie à énergie propre
avec zéro émission n'est d'ici 2030 et
mon gouvernement travaille en étroite
coopération avec notre congrès pour
faire des investissements dans la veille
dans l'infrastructure verte dans les
véhicules électriques pour nous
permettre de faire des progrès au niveau
national pour atteindre nos objectifs
climatiques et
en faisant ces
investissements ambitieux nous
préservons l'environnement mais nous
investissons également dans notre propre
avenir dans notre propre pays et c'est
une occasion extraordinaire de créer des
emplois bien rémunérés pour les
travailleurs de tous nos pays et pour
stimuler une croissance économique de
longue haleine pour améliorer les
conditions de vie de tous nos peuples
nous devons également
venir en aide au peuple aux personnes
qui ont été les plus durement touchés et
qu'ils ont le moins de ressources leur
permettant de s'adapter au mois d'avril
j'ai annoncé que les etats-unis allaient
doubler le financement public
international pour venir en aide aux
pays en développement et pas qu'elle
fasse face à la crise climatique
aujourd'hui j'ai l'honneur de vous
annoncer que nous allons travailler avec
le congrès pour doubler à nouveau ce
montant notamment pour reçu
subventionner les efforts d'adaptation
les états unis seront elles les premiers
en termes de financement de la lutte
climatique et grâce au
capital d autres bailleurs de fonds nous
allons mobiliser
le 100 milliards de dollars pour appuyer
l'action climatique dans les pays en
développement
alors que nous faisons face à ces crises
nous voyons l'avènement également d'une
aire de technologie de possibilités qui
pourraient
bouleverser tous les aspects de notre
vie à nous de déterminer si ces
technologies ils seront utilisés pour
autonomiser les populations ou accroître
la répression alors que les nouvelles
technologies évoluent nous allons
travailler avec nos partenaires
démocratiques pour faire en sorte que
les nouvelles avancées dans ce domaine
de la biotechnologie de l'informatique
quantique que de la 5g de l'intelligence
artificielle et bien plus encore soit
utilisée pour régler des problèmes
autonomiser les peuples promouvoir les
libertés à des êtres humains et non pas
pour bâillonner la dissidence ou prendre
pour cible les minorités les états unis
vont faire des investissements dans la
recherche dans l'innovation sans
précédent nous allons travailler avec
les pays à toutes les étapes du
développement économique pour élaborer
de nouveaux outils de nouvelles
technologies pour que nous puissions
relever les
défis des 25 années à venir et plus loin
encore nous avons renforcé notre
infrastructure critique face aux cyber
attaque nous avons perturbé les réseaux
de rançon j ciel nous
établissons un code de conduite très
clair pour toutes les nations concernant
le cyberespace nous nous réservons le
droit de riposter de façon décisive aux
cyberattaques qui menacent nos peuples
nos alliés nos intérêts nous allons
rechercher de nouvelles règles
commerciales de croissance économique
nous allons chercher à éviter que la
balance ne penche de façon artificielle
en faveur d'un pays au détriment
d'autres reports que tout le monde soit
sur un pied d'égalité car toutes les
nations ont le droit et doit avoir la
possibilité d'être dans une concurrence
loyale nous allons et garantir les
droits fondamentaux des garanties
environnementales faire en sorte que la
propriété intellectuelle soit un protégé
alors que les dividendes de la
mondialisation seront partagées dans
toutes nos sociétés et nous continuerons
de défendre énorme l'est règle
des relations internationales des
dernières décennies qui ont été
essentiels pour le développement des
nations de par le monde des engagements
tels que la liberté de navigation le
respect des droits des traités
internationaux le soutien des mesures de
maîtrise des armements pour réduire les
risques pour renforcer la transparence
notre approche
est pleinement conforme à la mission des
nations unies aux valeurs dont nous
sommes convenus lorsque nous avons
rédigé la charte
ce sont des engagements que nous avons
tous pris et que nous sommes tous tenus
de respecter alors que nous nous
efforçons de relever ces défis urgents
qu'ils soient nouveaux qu'ils existent
de longue date il nous faut également
travailler les uns avec les autres
toutes les grandes puissances du monde
ont pour devoir selon moi de bien gérer
leurs relations pour éviter que l'on
passe d'une concurrence responsable un
conflit les états unis
vont montrer l'exemple de leur valeur de
leurs forces seront en concurrence
défendront leurs alliés leurs amis
s'opposeront à toute tentative de pays
plus fort de dominer les pays plus
faibles ou d'imposer des changements des
territoires par la force par la
contrainte économique par l'exploitation
ou la désinformation mais je le répète
nous ne cherchons pas nous ne cherchons
pas une nouvelle guerre froide
nous ne cherchons pas un monde divisé en
bloc rigide les etats unis sont prêts à
travailler avec toute nation et qui
recherchera un règlement pacifique
des différends même si nous avons un
désaccord profond dans d'autres domaines
parce que nous espérons tous les
conséquences de notre échec si nous ne
nous unissons pas pour faire face à la
menace urgente de lakovic 19 des
changements climatiques au des menaces
prolonger la prolifération nucléaire
les états unis restent
résolus à empêcher l'iran d'acquérir
l'armé nucléaire nous travaillons avec
les p5 + 1 pour travailler sur la voie
diplomatique avec l'iran pour qu'il
revienne dans le
plan d'action commun nous sommes prêts à
dialoguer si l'iran fait de même de même
nos miseront sur la diplomatie pour
parvenir à la dénucléarisation complète
de la péninsule coréenne nous voulons
des
progrès concrets
pour pouvoir accroître la stabilité dans
la péninsule dans la région et par là
même améliorée elle la vie des habitants
de la rpdc il nous faut également rester
vigilant face à la menace terroriste qui
pèse sur toutes nos nations qui viennent
une menace qui vient des régions
lointaines du monde ou qui vient de
notre propre pays
nous savons que la menace terroriste est
réelle elle nous l'avons presque tout
connu
nous avons perdu le mois dernier 13
héros
américains ainsi que des afghans
héroïque dans une attaque tragique à
l'aéroport de kaboul ceux qui perpétuent
des actes terroristes contre nous
continuerons de trouver un ennemi
déterminé dans les états unis le monde
d'aujourd'hui n'est pas le monde de 2001
cela étant dit les états unis ne sont
plus le même pays que celui que nous
étions lorsque nous avons été attaqués
le 11 septembre il ya 20 ans aujourd'hui
nous sommes mieux capable de détecter de
prévenir des attaques terroristes nous
sommes plus résilient nous sommes plus
capables de les repousser d'un riposter
nous savons comment nouer des
partenariats
efficace pour démanteler les réseaux
terroristes nous attaquer à leurs
finances lutter contre leur propagande
les empêcher de se déplacer et par là
même éviter des attaques imminentes
nous faisons face aux menaces
terroristes d'aujourd'hui et de demain
en utilisant toute la panoplie d'outils
à notre disposition y compris travailler
en coopération avec nos partenaires
locaux de sorte à ce que nous ne devions
pas dépendre de déploiement militaire à
grande échelle l'une des façons
important dont nous pouvons renforcer la
sécurité et réduire la violence c'est de
chercher à améliorer la vie des peuples
de par le monde des peuples qu'ils
voient que leur gouvernement ne répond
pas à leurs besoins la corruption
alimentent les inégalités
et vient
détourner les ressources d'une nation se
propage par delà les frontières
provoque des souffrances humaines
c'est une menace pour la sécurité
nationale en ce 21ème siècle dans le
monde nous voyons de plus en plus les
citoyens clamer leur désenchantement
alors que les riches sont de plus en
plus riches et profite de pots-de-vin ne
respectent pas la loi alors que
l'écrasante majorité des personnes
n'arrivent pas à avoir un emploi ou à
mettre des aliments sont à la table
ou ne parviennent pas à envoyer leurs
enfants à l'école et des peuples sont
descendus dans la rue dans toutes les
régions pour exiger que leurs
gouvernements satisfasse les besoins
essentiels de la population que tout un
chacun et la possibilité de protéger
leurs droits et de prospérer par delà
les langues par delà les continents on
entend les peuples scandé cet appel à la
dignité la dignité
en tant que dirigeant nous avons pour
devoir de répondre à cet appel et non
pas de le bâillonner les etats-unis se
sont engagés à utiliser
leurs ressources et notre plateforme
internationale pour soutenir toutes ces
voix nouer des partenariats avec ces
personnes pour trouver des façons de
promouvoir la dignité de l'être humain
de par le monde par exemple
il est nécessaire de mise et il soit
l'infrastructure dans les pays en
développement
grâce à l'infrastructure
lorsque l'infrastructure et de faibles
de mauvaise qualité elle alimente la
corruption elle exacerbe la
détérioration de l'environnement et elle
ne fait qu'aggraver lé problème pour les
pays sur le long terme par contre si
l'on me sont des investissements
transparente durable et des projets qui
satisfasse les besoins de la population
en recrutant les travailleurs locaux
pour
garder des normes de travail de normes
environnementales très strictes à
l'infrastructure permettra aux sociétés
des pays à revenu intermédiaire de
prospérer de se développer c'est là
l'idée qui sous-tend ce projet
reconstruire en mieux aux côtés de nos
partenaires du g7 et du secteur privé
nous avons pour but de mobiliser des
centaines de millions de dollars
d'investissement dans l'infrastructure
en outre nous nous continuerons d'être
le principal bailleur de fonds
fournisseurs daide humanitaire pour
donner des aliments des articles
sanitaires un hébergement aux millions
de personnes qui en ont besoin lorsque
un typhon fait rage lorsqu'un séisme
frappe partout dans le monde nous serons
là nous sommes prêts à aider et à un
moment où une personne sur trois dans le
monde n'a pas accès à une alimentation
suffisante et ça c'est rien que l'année
dernière les etats-unis se sont engagés
à mobiliser ses partenaires pour lutter
contre la malnutrition et pour faire en
sorte que nous puissions nourrir le
monde pendant les décennies à venir à
cette fin les états unis
s'engage à consacrer 10 milliards de
dollar à lutter contre la famine au
niveau national et international depuis
2000 les et le gouvernement des états
unis a fourni 140 milliards de dollars
pour promouvoir la santé le renforcement
des systèmes sanitaires et nous
continuerons de promouvoir ces
investissements essentiels pour que l
avis des personnes s'améliore au
quotidien pour leur donner une petite
marge de manoeuvre alors que nous
essayons d'améliorer les conditions de
vie et il nous faut
mettre un terme à ces conflits synonyme
de douleurs de souffrance par le monde
il le faut nous engager en faveur de
négociations politiques de la diplomatie
et non pas de la violence pour gérer les
tensions qui existent de par le monde il
nous faut tendre à un avenir de paix de
sécurité pour tous et toutes au
moyen-orient les etats-unis se sont
engagés
en faveur d'un état juif indépendant et
c'est un engagement in équivoque mais je
reste convaincu que la solution à deux
états reste la meilleure façon de faire
en sorte que la terre d'israël en tant
qu'etat juif puisse vivre
aux côtés d'un état palestinien
instable cela reste la solution nous
sommes bien loin de cet objectif pour le
moment jamais nous ne pouvons nous
permettre
d'abandonner de renoncer à la
possibilité de progrès nous ne pouvons
pas renoncer à régler des conflits tels
que celui des copies de yémen
où lé conflit entre les parties provoque
des vagues de famine de viau lui lance
de violations des droits humains du
recours constant au viol en tant qu'arme
de guerre nous continuerons de
travailler avec la communauté internet
lionel pour promouvoir la paix et mettre
un terme à ses souffrances
alors que
nous misons sur la diplomatie nous
défendrons les valeurs démocratiques qui
touche au coeur même de qui nous sommes
en tant qu' un peuple la liberté
l'égalité les perspectives d'avenir et
la conviction fondamentale des droits
universels de tout un chacun c'est dans
l'adn même de notre nation
et c'est dans l'adn même de cette
institution
parfois
nous oublions
est le préambule de la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme le
droit et les droits égaux et
inaliénables de tous les membres de la
famille des nations unies représente la
base de la liberté de la justice et de
la paix dans le monde
le credo fondateur des nations unies qui
place l'individu au coeur même de notre
système
est cette
vision cette vérité ne peut être oublié
ou mal interprétés les etats unis
feront le nécessaire mais notre impact
sera plus grand si toutes les nations
assument ensemble la mission qui nous a
été confiée voilà pourquoi
sans nation ont soutenu une déclaration
au conseil de sécurité qui a adopté une
résolution sur l'api qui sera apportée
au peuple afghan à l'avenir en précisant
les ce que l'on attendait des talibans
en termes de respect des droits humains
universels nous tous devons défendre le
droit des femmes et des filles à
pleinement
exploiter leur potentiel apporter leur
contribution économique politique et
sociale et pour pouvoir réaliser leur
rêve bien loin de la violence et des
indés de l'intimidation de l'amérique
latine au moyen-orient en afghanistan
partout dans le monde il nous faut
toujours condamné l'oppression et le
fait de prendre pour cible les minorités
religieuses ou ethniques que cela
survienne aching jeunes au nord de
l'ethiopie où que ce soit dans le monde
ensemble nous devons défendre les droits
de la communauté lgbt cueilli de sorte
qu'elle puisse vivre ouvertement sans
rien craindre qu'il s'agit du cameroun
la tchétchénie ou d'ailleurs
alors que notre nation avance vers ce
tournant et s'efforce de relever les
grands défis transversaux de notre
époque sachez que je ne suis pas
agnostique quant à l'avenir que nous
voulons pour le monde
l'avenir appartiendra à ceux qui
soutiennent et non pas qu'ils foulent
aux pieds la dignité humaine est
l'avenir appartiendra à ceux qui
permettent à la population d'exploiter
son pien son plein potentiel
l'avenir appartient à ceux et celles qui
donnent roman à leur population la
possibilité de respirer et non pas à
ceux qui suffoque roller population avec
une main de fer
d'aucuns affirment que
en a sonné le glas de la démocratie
c'est ce que disent les autocrates mais
le fait est que le monde démocratique il
est partout il vit dans les militants
anticorruption dans les défenseurs des
droits de l'homme dans les journalistes
dans les manifestants pour la paix
au bélarus birmanie cuba venezuela et
partout ailleurs il vit il vit dans les
soudanaises courageuses qui ont fait
face à la violence et l'oppression pour
évincer à un dictateur génocidaire et
qui au quotidien s'efforce de défendre
le progrès démocratique et le vit dans
les habitants du moldova un très fiers
qu'ils ont pu faire gagner les forces de
la démocratie
et qui vont bâtir une économie inclusive
il le vit dans le peuple de la zambie
qui pour la première fois utilisé son
pouvoir de vote et qui a participé pour
dénoncer la corruption
et ouvrir une nouvelle voie pour le pays
aucune démocratie n'est parfaite et cela
vaut également pour les états unis mais
nous continuerons de défendre les plus
grands idéaux panser nos plaies
pour faire face aux violences à
l'insurrection la démocratie reste le
meilleur outil à notre disposition pour
permettre au plein potentiel humain de
s'exprimer mesdames et messieurs
l'heure est venue pour nous
de prouver que nous sommes à la hauteur
de ceux qui nous ont précédés que nous
avons confiance en notre avenir commun
ils les ont bâties les nations unies
rompu le cercle vicieux de la violence
et ont marqué l'avènement de décennies
de paix relative et de prospérité
commune aujourd'hui le moment est venu
ensemble de réitérer cette humanité qui
nous rassemble qui est bien plus
importante que nos divergences ou que
nos désaccords choisissons de faire plus
que ce que nous pouvons faire un seul
pour pouvoir accomplir ce que nous
devons accomplir ensemble face à cette
pandémie faisons en sorte d'être mieux
préparés pour la suivante faisons
reculer les changements climatiques
accroissons notre résilience
face aux impacts que nous voyons dans et
déjà garantissons un avenir où la
technologie sera un outil
au service des êtres humains pas un
outil de la répression voilà les défis
que nous avons à relever pour voir quel
monde nous allons léguer à nos enfants
et petits enfants nous ne pouvons
relever que ces défis que en nous
tournant vers l'avenir
aujourd'hui je me tiens devant vous pour
la première fois en vingt ans les états
unis ne sont pas en guerre nous avons
tourné la page
toute l'énergie toutes les ressources de
notre nation se concentre désormais sur
demain et non pas three year je sais ce
si
demain
nous jouerons un rôle de premier plan
pour relever tous les grands défis
qu'ovide climat paix sécurité dignité
trois humains
mais nous ne le ferons pas seuls nous
jouerons ce rôle de premier plan en
coopération avec nos alliés nos
partenaires et tous ceux et celles qui
comme nous croient que nous pouvons le
faire que nous pouvons relever ce défi
que nous pouvons bâtir cet avenir
qu ensemble nous pouvons préserver notre
planète rien n'est d'inévitables tout
est un choix et je puis vous dire ce que
veulent les etats-unis nous choisirons
un avenir meilleur nous vous et moi
avons la capacité et la volonté de bâtir
un monde meilleur nous nous ne pouvons
nous permettre de perdre une seule
seconde supplémentaire mettons nous au
travail
bâtissons cet avenir meilleur dès
maintenant nous pouvons le faire nous en
avons le pouvoir nous en avons les
capacités
merci que dieu vous bénisse
gameloft au nom de l'assemblée générale
je remercie le président des états unis
d'amérique pour
son allocution je demande au protocole
de bien vouloir